[music]
>> Brother Muhammad Hisham from Singapore.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
My respected elders,
brothers, and all those watching at
home, I greet you with the most
heartwarming and blessed of greetings.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Once again, I just want to highlight I
received my acceptance
on the last minute.
Thereafter,
I received my visa,
or should I say on the final hour.
And with with that,
more or less, I'm not so well prepared
like I hoped so.
So, a little something about me.
When people ask me,
"How are you, brother?"
I always answer,
"I'm still alive."
I believe uh
brother Farik and brother Kaleem knows
this very well.
Indirectly,
when I say this,
people always astaghfirullah and give me
a stare.
Actually, indirectly, I'm doing dawah
so that they know
and be reminded about death.
So, my kind of thinking is always unique
and different.
So, I asked around
at the brothers what were the uh topics
were going to be about.
So, okay. So,
in order to be unique and to uh be of
interest to Dr. Zakir Naik, my topic on
this short
1 and 1/2 minute would be on LGBT,
inshallah.
LGBT
is not a new phenomena.
It has been eradicated.
And now,
on this 21st century,
it is re-emerging.
Research and studies have shown that the
human form has only two,
male
and female.
44 XX chromosomes
will categorize you as a female, and 44
XY
will be a male.
But, these LGBTs, they're trying, you
know,
to show that, "Hey,
otherwise."
Innately, research and studies have
proven, masha Allah,
that the male form will be interested in
the opposite form, the female,
and vice versa.
Whatever they they're trying to do,
I say this,
believe in the Quran. As Dr. Zakir Naik
has proven, 4/5 of the Quran has been
proven to be 100% true.
So, in that case, we follow what the
Quran says.
If
your desires is towards the same sex and
it's not beneficial for you,
we shall follow the Quran,
which has been revealed to Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
So, with this, I would like to end
from Surah Zalzalah.
For every single good deed that you do,
or atoms worth,
will be rewarded or noted. For any every
bad deed that you do, shall be noted. Wa
akhiru dawana alhamdulillah rabbil
alamin. As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Brother Abdul Malik Badeges from
Indonesia.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
I would like to open my talk
with Islamic greeting. As-salamu alaykum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
I would like to talk about Islam and
pluralism.
Nowadays,
some people
think that every religion is the same.
We are praying to the same God.
But, is that true?
The idea of pluralism has been growing.
If there is something happens
and the media
takes Islam in it, they're trying to
relate between that
case with Islam, like terrorism attack
and so on. There will be a thousand
of comments saying that every religion
is the same. We don't need religion
because of this, we are in war.
But, is that true?
Before I continue, let's talk about the
concept of God in Islam.
The concept of God in Islam is based on
the divine law.
It is not based on imagination by
artist.
It is not an intuition
by
some artistic person.
And it's not based on
what people say,
what the Bible makers have made.
Allah is the one.
Qul hu Allahu ahad.
Allah is the one and only. Allahu samad,
the everlasting, the eternal.
And the verse
is Allah's sayings,
sayings about himself, about the
creation, about the relation between the
creation and himself.
So, it's very clear.
And the road to the salvation has been
told to Rasulullah sallallahu alayhi
wasallam,
to ummah,
to our people,
to everyone in this world.
And Islam is the substance of the
previous holy books, Torah.
And let's answer
this pluralism with an analogy.
If we are studying in one school,
let's say the headmaster is Allah,
and the students are us, the people.
Is it possible to have more than one
rule?
Is it possible to have a thousand of
rules?
So, it's impossible.
And Allah has answered this in the
Quran.
It is he who sent his messenger bil
huda, with guidance, wa dinil haq, and
the truth of
the
and the and the religion of the truth.
Liyuzhirahu alad dini kullihi, to
proclaim it over all the religion, walau
karihal mushrikun, even though the
pagans detest it. So, Allah has answered
the idea of pluralism long time ago.
Billahi tawfiq wal hidayah. As-salamu
alaykum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.
Brother Rehman Yunus from India.
Alhamdulillah.
Was-salatu was-salam ala Rasulillah.
Wa ala alihi wa ashabihi ajma'in.
Amma ba'd.
A'udhu billahi min ash-shaytani rajim.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
Wasta'inu bis-sabri was-salah. Wa innaha
lakabiratun illa alal khashi'in.
Rabbi shrah li sadri. Wa yassir li amri.
Wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu qawli.
Today, I'll be talking about patience,
which is similar to our which is similar
to the topic of brother Ibrahim.
And as I've started my talk with the
quotation from holy Quran, from Surah
al-Baqarah,
chapter number two,
verse number 45, it says, "Wasta'inu
bis-sabri was-salah. Wa innaha Wa innaha
lakabiratun illa alal khashi'in."
That means, seek help with patience and
salah, and this
is very heavy.
It's very heavy. Truly, it's very hard
for the except for those who be who are
khashin, who believe in Allah, who seek
help from Allah, who afraid from Allah.
And this is the and the next one is it
for example, when we offer salah, we
need sabr.
When we work in our respective
workplaces, we need sabr. We are
married, we need sabr. If we are not
married, even we need sabr. And for
example, someone is if we are teaching,
we need sabr.
And if you're learning something, we
need sabr. If someone passes away in
your family, we need sabr. What can we
do apart from that? We can just say,
"Inna lillahi wa inna ilayhi raji'un."
Everything comes from Allah and
everything return backs to Allah. And
apart from that, we can just bear
patience. And then
the next one is the next part in this is
for example, when some if you need some
help, you have some code for that. And
here, for example, if you want to
seek some help from the police, you need
a code and you have to dial the dial
code of the particular country. And then
Allah Ta'ala says in the same chapter,
which is similar, which says in the
Surah Baqarah, chapter number two, verse
number 153.
Ya ayyuhallazina amanu ista'inu
bis-sabri was-salah. Inna Allaha
ma'as-sabirin.
Oh you believers, who believe in Allah,
seek help with patience and salah.
Verily, Allah is with those who are
sabirin. Imagine, our Khaliq, our Raziq
is with us, who are the people who bear
with the patience.
And the last part in Allah Ta'ala says
in Surah Al-Mulk, chapter number 67,
verse number two.
Alladhi khalaqal-mawta wal-hayata. Allah
will surely test you. Why? Because Allah
has created life and death, so that he
may test you which one amongst you are
the best. And then
Allah says and again in Surah Baqarah,
chapter number two, verse number 155,
which says Walana bluwan nakum bi
shai'im minal khawfi wal ju'i wa
wal anfusi was-samarat. Wa
bashshirish-shabirin.
It which means Allah will test you with
minal khawf, that is fear.
Minal khawfi wal ju', with hunger.
Walanaksim minal amwal, that is the loss
of wealth.
Wal anfusi was-samarat, that is the
fruits, that is life and the fruits and
give glad tidings to those who bear with
patience. Wa akhiru da'wana anil hamdu
lillahi rabbil alamin.
>> [music]
[singing]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allahu Allahu
Ya Rabbi Ya Allah.
Allahu
Ya
Rabbi Ya Allah.